I'm Tria like an object like a trophy
and once they're done using that trophy
to parade around their friends or like
show off like oh yeah I did this with
her it's like okay you're done bye
that's
it all right
Bri Bri uh where you from originally
where'd you grow up um I'm from Panama
like the country not the City Central
America yeah um I grew up there until I
was
16 years old no like 18 years old so how
was your
childhood um it was not the best um I
had like like my parents divorced when I
was young um I moved in with my mom and
we didn't have like the best living
situation um she was just very like she
had an abusive boyfriend
so he would like abuse her in front of
us and I always had to like jump in and
stop and that was pretty traumatic so
it's pretty pretty not and your parents
are from Panama my dad is from here well
he's my stepdad he's from here from
United States yeah from California okay
and then my mom she's from pan
yeah
so and so aside from the divorce was
there anything anything else any rough
spots in your in your upbringing um she
was very abusive towards me when I was
young she um would hit me a lot I feel
like she was taking it out on me
because her boyfriend was abusive to her
so she would like have to take it out on
somebody so she would like she would hit
me a lot she would say really bad things
to me um she was also very narcissistic
and she would like tell me and my sister
that we always had to look perfect or be
perfect in order for her to bring us
around her like friends and stuff and
when I was was young she would like I
don't know what the word is but she
would have like older guy friends and
she would always bring me around and say
look how pretty my daughter is isn't she
so sexy and stuff and I was like a child
and so I've been sexualized since I was
very young by my own mother by your mom
yeah oh so it's pretty bad what kind of
what kind of teenager were you I was
very good until I turned 16 like 15 16 I
started to Rebel just because she was so
strict um she would be like I don't know
I decided to start rebelling so they
sent me up to America for 6 months but
soon as I got to America I would sneak
out I would do drugs I would drink um so
they sent me back to Panama and then
when they sent me back to Panama I kept
doing the rebellious stuff so my mom
kicked me out the house when I was 16
and she kicked me out with nothing like
she basically told me take your mattress
and your phone and go I couldn't even
take my clothes couldn't take anything
um I had nowhere to go so I was staying
on my cousin's couch for a while I would
stay like with friends sometimes but it
was pretty like rough to like find
somewhere to stay because everyone would
eventually get tired and be like all
right you have to go so um one day when
I was 17 I met this 30-year-old guy at
the bus stop and I was so desperate that
I didn't have any anywhere to stay that
I asked him like can I come stay with
you and then I started Living and dating
with a 30-year-old when I was 17 so that
wasn't very good but it was what I had
to do mhm and this was where this was
all in Panama all in Panama yeah but you
you had been going to the United States
um they just sent me here for 6 months
trying to like they're saying to like
fix me like make me act better but I
wasn't so they just sent me back to
Panama how is growing up in Panama
different than growing up in in the US
oh it's like extreme poverty over there
like we lived in like the
slums basically we didn't really like my
mom would leave us and we didn't really
like have food for a couple days um we
survived off like mac and cheese like
the craft mac and cheese so you grew up
in pretty extreme poverty yeah it was it
was pretty bad like we didn't really
have much but she would always paint
this picture like everything was perfect
everything was
fine and it wasn't really fine so it was
pretty hard how far did you in school um
I graduated high school and I graduated
college too but that so first basically
how happened when I was
17 um I decided I got very suicidal very
depressed I was like okay if something
doesn't happen I'm literally just
wanting to die so then I applied to
college just one college and I got
accepted and once I it what school
Florida state Florida State yeah so when
I once I got accepted I was like okay
now I have something to live for my
grandparents had told me that they were
going to help me pay for college um as
soon as they sent me back here I mean
back to Panama they cut me off
completely I'd like to thank better help
for being a sponsor of today's video I
think a lot of my viewers are going
through things just like we all are
whether you're a viewer or not of this
channel I think everybody goes through
something and whether it's depression or
anxiety or you're just going through a
tough period of your life talking with a
professional can be really helpful you
know personally I go through just the
stress of talking to so many people that
are going through tough times tough
tough stories is hard on me and and
talking with a therapist is really
helpful so I I just started doing that
recently it's been really great for me
I'm I'm a huge fan of therapy and with
better help you can have your therapy
session as a phone call or a video
session or even messaging if you prefer
whatever is most comfortable for you I
did mine as as video which is great it's
it's just like being in their office but
you're doing it from the comfort of your
own
home and my better help therapist has
been wonderful right right from the
get-go he he kind of figured out what
what my deal is and was really helpful
and what's great about better help is
you get paired with a therapist you're
matched within 48 hours in most cases if
you're just not feeling it with your
therapist you can try another one or you
can try as many times as you like until
you find someone that you're comfortable
with and you can do that a no additional
charge which is really nice so if you'd
like to join the over four million
people that have taken charge of their
mental health by talking with an
experienced betterhelp therapist you can
actually get 10% off by going to
betterhelp.com sof white underbelly or
click on the link in the video
description box below thank you for
watching and now back to the video so
now I'm in college and I have no money
or anything and all my family cut me off
so I had no money at all and I had to
pay for college if I wanted to stay in
there so I
basically um while I was living with the
guy there's like this like Hooters kind
of bar but a little more
like sexual I was still 17 um it was
more like Hooters but strip club kind of
Vibes so I just walked in one day with
my last $5 and I was like hey can I work
here and they were like yeah go change
right now they didn't ask me for my age
they didn't ask me for an ID nothing
they're like go change right now and
come back so I was like okay I went I
came back started working it was
horrible men would touch you men would
like grope you you had to like get drunk
every night with the guys and it was
just like it wasn't very fun but it was
what I had to do and then one day I'd
make enough to pay rent and like put
towards paying for my semester but not
enough to really
survive so I was kind of working to just
like be able to pay for college
so one day I'm just sitting there and I
go on my phone and on Instagram I
started getting thousands of requests
someone had post my posted my picture
and it went viral and I had just turned
18 and I was like you know what this is
one only fans was like really like
blowing up and I was like you know what
I'm going make an only fans so I decided
to make an only fans that when I had
just turned 18 um and that was
life-changing in the first month I made
$220,000 which I had never seen that
kind of money before so I got kind of
addicted to it like addicted to the fast
life um and to the fast money so I would
keep doing worse and worse things like I
started off like pretty py then I would
like go into lre and then I would go
farther and far
and I regret that so much why would you
go farther because the guys were
requesting it yeah because if you don't
the money is going to like dwindle down
and it's a DI if you do something more
extreme yeah you'll keep making more
money yeah so I decided to like how much
were you making at the peak I made
$100,000 on my best month $ 100,000
100,000 a month yeah for a 18y old girl
yeah I yeah I made 100,000 and I was
making that for
months um and I just kept but I was so
depressed when I was doing it it was it
was so bad I would lay in bed every day
like how did this become my life like
how did I end up here like the money was
great it was amazing I could pay for
everything I bought my car my apartment
was able to buy anything I want but I
wasn't happy because of what I was doing
to make that money and I wanted to do
more with my life but I was Stu stuck in
this contract with a management company
that they're basically like internet
pimps they take a girl they say oh we're
going to manage everything you do and
you're going to give us a percentage so
I had them and I was stuck in a
year-long contract so there's no way I
could have broken out of it um unless I
like paid a crazy fine or something I
don't remember how to break the contract
what what percentage of the money were
they were they taking um like 35 35% so
if you're making 100,000 they get 30 of
that 35,000 of that
so it was it was like kind of like I was
stuck like there's nowhere to go and I
still wanted to and when I started
making that money my mom came back and
she was like oh I love you again because
I have all this money so I was kind of
buying her love like buying her gifts
giving her money all the time just and
when I wouldn't she would kind of like
get mad so I just kept giving her more
and more and she kind of just took
advantage of the fact that I really
wanted her to love me since she never
gave me that love as a child so I
decided to like give her more money and
more money and it was just so depressing
like I had no real friends all my
friends just liked me because of what I
could do or what I could give them um I
really had nobody so it was really a
lonely time in my life did
you keep the you know so your sister was
younger or older yeah she was younger
she was um four years younger than me
but she had completely cut my mom off
completely cut me off she cut everybody
off because of how traumatic our
childhood was they sent her up to
America and she just never came back
like they were like oh she's just coming
for a month and my grandpa parents kept
her because they were like there's no
way you're going back there do you speak
with her now yeah we finally like this
year like started to talk again she's
kind of forgiving everything I didn't
really do anything but just because she
felt like I was still good with my mom
she was like she's also a bad person but
I just I just desperately wanted my mom
to love me so I was willing to deal with
everything you're also just trying to
make money to to survive your intention
was not to become a millionaire at 18
yeah it was it was crazy I didn't know
what to do I I spent a lot of it like I
didn't know what to do with it I would
buy like a crazy car I would buy like
all these clothes all these luxury items
because an 18-year-old with $100,000 a
month is going to go crazy like they're
not going to know how to invest it how
to like do what they have to do with it
but I was still paying for college and
staying in college this whole time
that's great yeah so so you you tell me
what happened with only fans cuz um I
kept going
until everything was all over the
Internet and my family would see it my
friends would see it everybody in Panama
knew about it like Panama is a very
small country so everybody in Panama
knew who I was they knew what I was
doing and every time I went out side
they're like oh she's that only fans
girl that does this and this and this
and it was just very like hard to like
meet people and like have genuine
connections because everyone just had
like this bad image of you and they were
judging you all the time so I couldn't
really like make friends I didn't really
have anybody yeah so I just kept going
with it and then I was just so depressed
it was it got so bad that I was like I
have to stop St like this is something I
have to stop doing because it's going to
what really happened is my Instagram
account got banned and I just never came
back I was like okay I'm done like this
is my chance to escape this is my chance
to stop it's so hard to escape from that
life once you start making Fast Money
it's like you want to keep making fast
money that was my next question how do
you stop making 100 Grand a month um I I
had enough saved up where I was like
I'll probably be good um there's some
problems with actually getting the money
because in Panama all the banks
blacklisted me so there was no way to
actually get the money so what I did was
I had it in a account in China and I
would take out cash every day from the
ATM so wow yeah that was bad the stigma
of being a sex worker in Panama is much
worse than they definitely yeah they but
but when I came to America they did the
same thing a couple banks did the same
thing when I started putting the money
in and they were like into an American
bank account so I didn't have to take it
out the ATM every day and they were just
like where did this money come from so I
told them and they're like we don't
accept that a lot of banks have that
where they don't accept they have like a
morality Clause where they don't accept
money like that which is still legal
money so I don't really understand that
but it's like oh you got it from posting
naked pictures you're done so yeah the
stigma of sex is still yeah a big thing
definely even today yeah I were you
raised with a religious background or
anything like that my family was
Catholic but they didn't do anything
that Catholics they were alcoholics they
all do do terrible things so it really
wasn't a religious no thing for you it
was really just the shame of yeah doing
something that you didn't feel good
about and everyone just knowing
everyone just knowing like when I came
up here even when I went to college
everyone knew everyone finds out even to
this day I sto this I'm 22 now um I st
this when I was 20 years
old and it's still following me to this
day anywhere I go everyone will always
find out um no matter what like there's
not a single person that I meet that
doesn't find out somehow they're like
cool at the beginning and they like me
and I have friends and then it's as soon
as they find out they're like is this oh
is this because you're on only fans or
because people take your videos or
photos from only fans and they'll post
them somewhere else I think they just
don't they just judge me off the fact
that I did that no but how do they know
you did that um well since it's all over
the Internet so so that was my question
so it's all over the internet not not
all over only fans but also on other
platforms yeah like other websites on
Google everywhere it's everywhere really
yeah I can't do anything anything like I
have people that try to take it down but
there's just so much of it that you
can't get rid of all of it how does this
make you
feel it's crazy that something I did
that I was so dumb and naive and young I
was only 18 years old like I was
desperate I had no way to survive and I
really wanted to pay for college and now
it's going to follow me for the rest of
my life like I'm stuck with that for the
rest of my life
so now I'm trying to kind of like
Rebrand myself and like um I still have
some of the money like I spent a lot of
it um but you're 18 yeah you 18-year old
$100,000 what what do you think they're
going to do yeah I have like 20% how
much is it like 2 million I have like
30% of it left so that I have in
Investments and stuff and I still um I
want to go to law school and become a
lawyer good for you yeah so I'm trying
to like save that money up and build it
so starting a business like I really
want to like do better things with my
life um that's great yeah I'm I want to
go to just as an outsider hearing your
story you didn't do anything terrible
yeah you didn't do something that's like
but it just feel evil and all that it's
just like you're just a young girl
trying to make some money you're
certainly beautiful and I'm sure every
Hustler you come across is going to
steer you towards something like that
yeah and sometimes it no one's going to
help no one's going to be helping you
trying to get into law school yeah so
it's admirable that you've done that on
your own yeah it's very hard because
it's still so tempting to go back even
after all the regret just the fast life
is just so tempting to go back to that
so yeah that's really hard you got to
remember the
emotional toll that you pay for that
though that it took on me and um now on
Instagram I have all these followers but
they all know me because of that um I
hang out with very important people
sometimes and they all just know about
it and it's it's crazy are you able to
forgive yourself cuz I I mean to me it's
not that horrible what you
did um and even if it was it was just
like you know you're not murdering
anybody you're not really doing anything
that terrible but if if you if you have
this terrible shame and guilt yeah then
you're that's almost worse than whatever
you've
done yeah it's just hard I also have
like mental health issues so that also
really affected me like I just I it
really like I think about it every day
did you have those problems before no
you ever started No I um I I have
bipolar disorder and that started when
so bipolar is sort of the way it works
is it doesn't start like presenting
itself until you're like 20 so when I
stopped I got I started becoming Manic
and having episodes and I would do
really crazy things like really
dangerous things um spend a lot of money
that's why I spent most of my money from
only fans like now I don't really have
that backup plan because I did all of
those things when I was young and also
because of my issues so it's just a lot
on me like I have that behind me I have
my mental health issues I have my Trauma
from my childhood like my mom it's just
a lot of things that affect me every day
do you have friends now I have like two
close friends that's all you need yeah
um they kind of accept me for who I am
and they don't care about what people
say or when people are like why why are
you friends with her like she did this
like they do see it even if it's not
understand do see it it's that bad but
you have to understand how many people
are so uptight about sex yeah like um
especially when you profit off of it
they're fine with sex they're fine with
seeing all these things but when you're
profiting off of it they're like oh
like why are you doing that you're
a terrible person like how your parents
don't love you like all these crazy
things and I hear that every day on the
internet and it's like a lot to hear
every day yeah but but you have to
factor in the fact that you're very
attractive so you're going to get extra
envy and hate just because of that and
then oh you're
you're doing sex work and so that just
means you're a horrible person which is
not yeah especially girls girls are very
judgmental towards me I have literally
no girlfriends because they meet me
they're like already like uh like they
don't really like me and then especially
when they see all the attention that I
get they're like oh no like you're cut
off so you're a threat yeah I definitely
don't have any girlfriends they don't
like
me so that's pretty hard cuz I really
just want some friends that I could like
go out to dinner with or like do these
things with right now the only way I
like go out and do fun things is when
it's a guy trying to like get with me
basically like it's just a guy that
wants to even when you think he's a good
guy and he's just meeting you and he
wants to get to know you it always ends
up just being like they want to have sex
with you because they see that on the
internet and they're like this is all
she is worth like and there's way more
to me than that I have like I have
values I am an investor I'm smart I'm
starting a business like I own
properties like there's a lot more to me
but they just see that so and they don't
care to learn more yeah women that have
like accomplishments that look like you
do I think have it hardest because you
you get every guy every female and male
will will see you a certain way yeah and
if you were if you were less attractive
it'd be much easier for you it's very
lonely for sure i' I hate saying that
because I have a lot of like self-esteem
issues but I do think if I wasn't pretty
that I would have more friends and I
don't know I just sometimes wish that I
just wasn't pretty yeah I understand
it's kind of hard because I'm like okay
girls don't like me guys just want to
have sex with
me I have nobody basically I have nobody
I one gay best friend and then one sort
of girl friend but she's kind of not my
friend and that's it so and and the and
the the tragedy of this another part of
it that sucks is like so you're
wearing uh what some people would call a
sexy outfit yeah you could be wearing a
potato sack but who wants to wear a
potato sack yeah you know you're you're
young and beautiful you should allow you
know you should be free to do that
but by doing that you're you're going to
get more of the Judgment more of the
hate more of the Envy yeah it's a shame
it is like it's very hard I like to
dress a certain way and they see me as
like a but another girl could wear
the same exact thing or post the same
exact picture and no one will say
anything yeah because I'm just seen that
way automatically especially when they
find out what I do or what I did what
you did yeah what did you learn about
men from that experience I don't trust
men at all at all like every man I'm I
have such bad like anxiety and trust
issues and I just can't trust anybody I
don't trust women I don't trust men I I
don't trust my family because how can I
trust when the people who I was supposed
to trust like my parents couldn't even
give me love like how am I supposed to
know what love is when the people that
are supposed to be there for you weren't
there for you
so there's no way that I could trust
anybody it's I have gone to 10 years of
therapy and I still have the same
problem right now like there's really so
much going on in my head I think a lot
of very attractive females especially
much more than
males and whether they're sex workers or
not probably have similar stories about
inability to make quality
friends inability to get treated like a
real person the treatment you get from
men it's it's I'm Tre like an object
like a trophy and once they're done
using that trophy to parade around their
friends or like show off like oh yeah I
did this with her it's like okay you're
done bye that's it so I'm so used to
that that I think every man is like that
there's I always wonder if I'll ever get
married or have a serious relationship
because after 3 months they're like all
right like enough of you move on I think
I think I mean sounds like you're
intelligent as well you need to use the
your intelligence to screen
out the good from the bad I've tried but
it always ends up like it's bad right
so I try to give people chances but as
soon as I do I have this wall up as soon
as I slightly let the wall down they
show me why I should never let the wall
down and I just so gotten so used to
being hurt by everybody that it's like
that's what I expect now like have you
have you ever had a good relationship
with a man no never never not even like
not even just like a friendship or like
my parents or like my family members
nobody no man has ever treated me with
respect or love
so I don't know what love is and I don't
know if I'll ever know what love is and
this is all even without the only fans
stuff but the only fans stuff on top of
that yeah only fans is like pouring
gasoline on a fire yeah it was already a
problem before only fans yeah yeah for
sure and now it's just like but I feel
like I was I didn't see it that bad at
the time when I was sexualizing myself
on the internet because since I was
little my mom was doing it so I kind of
thought it was normal so when I started
I didn't see it as that bad but now that
I'm older and more mature and all this
stuff has happened I look back and it's
like like wow why did you do that yeah
no I don't I don't want to steer you in
the wrong direction but it's got to be
tempting to think about how much money
you could be making for the
next that's why it's so temp I think
about it every day like I'm like so it
takes a a very strong person to turn
that down yeah I think about every day
I'm life because every time you want
to take a trip or or buy a car or or
find a nicer place to live you know
there's a way that you
could and get that with bipolar and your
manic episodes the main thing is
spending money so when I have those
episodes I go crazy like I'll spend
10,000 20,000 a week of what I have
saved up like it's insane so your
restraint is admirable yeah it's pretty
impressive cuz I think 99% of women in
your shoes would would go back would
give in it's it's really hard and then
and then the solution to the Depression
was just like drugs or alcohol yeah for
sure like I would just turn to that to
escape you would do that as well yeah I
would I would I had really bad alcohol
problems where I would just black out
every day just to kind of forget it was
like the solution to all my problems
like okay anxiety like everyone judging
you all this stuff and people actually
liked me more when I was blackout drunk
like people I had a lot of friends like
party friends when we were all like
doing bad things together like then they
liked me but as soon as I tried to like
clean my life up and like turned to a
better side then they're like oh no like
we hate you now like they're like okay
we're done with you but yeah I
definitely had my like my phase where I
would black out every day um go crazy do
drugs it was it was pretty crazy are you
doing better now yeah I can't drink
because of the medicine that I'm on for
the bipolar that's good so I can't drink
but sometimes I do feel like it would
just be easy if I just was doing drugs
or alcohol like it would just be better
no it wouldn't but I know it's an Escape
that is not good but is an escape and
that's all you really want to do we're
all just trying to like escape from
reality and that's a that's a good
Escape but I but I I think it's super
important for you to have people that
are that understand your dilemma yeah
and are
supportive yeah because it takes a lot
of strength for you to walk this tight
tight rope yeah of not giving into the
temptation to just make another million
or two every year yeah CU you could be
making a lot more than one or two
million I know and I see all these girls
I that on Instagram that are doing it
and they're like making milons like love
it it's amazing and I'm like so tempting
to go back
but I'm like should I should I not but I
really don't I don't want you should not
yeah trust me yeah it's there's
there's there's a better life for you
than than that yeah I can guarantee you
that cuz I want to like do all the
business stuff and like law school and
stuff I really want to like be able to
do that I think if I were to go back to
that there's no way any law firm would
hire me like maybe if it was like so
long ago you know what I I I think the
the world is changing and technology is
changing and
the
Working World is is so many things are
changing quickly yeah by the time you're
like let's say you went to law school or
did something similar to that yeah by
the time you're ready to like join the
the you know the world again in terms of
doing being a lawyer or whatever you're
going to have some opportunity to do
something that where that isn't going to
be a problem I just hope so like I want
to start my own Law Firm that's my goal
yeah I mean do it do it yourself and
just start my own Law Firm it's almost
like just you have to forgive yourself
completely
forgive yourself completely understand
the negative treatment you get from
women and and men and if you see through
all that
it'll be easier for you to
forgive yourself it'll EAS easier it'll
be easier for you to love yourself and
do something great in the world that
makes you happy makes you proud for sure
cuz you haven't done anything really
that you're proud of yeah you know um
the most proud I've been is that I
graduated college that insane to me
great no that's something proud of there
you go yeah the graduating college
because everyone thought oh she's going
to get pregnant at 17 oh she's going to
do this oh she's going to do that she's
going to like have a terrible life
because of what she did and I kind of
prove them wrong every time they're like
she can't graduate college so I did um
she can't start anything productive so
I'm starting businesses like I have
Investments and properties like I have
all these things that they said that I
would never be able to do so it's like
there is more to me you guys just don't
know like there's way more to me than
just what is on the screen um I believe
it yeah they definitely just see this
Persona and they're like that's who she
is but once you get to know me you're
like okay that's not who she is but no
one has really taken the time or an
effort to get to know me do do you still
have hope that there is somebody male or
female friends or or romantic partners
that that
can see the real you and get past all
that
crap maybe I'll like one day I will I'm
telling you there is I'm just find
somebody get married have kids like be
able to grow together I just have to
find that person because my last
relationship it was an abusive
relationship anyways so it wasn't going
to work out anyways but he always said
he accepted me for that so that's why I
truly felt like I had to be with him
even if you were you helping him with
money no but he was abusive um and I
kind of felt like I had to be with him
cuz no one else was going to love me
because of what I did so um he would
kind of insinuate that and then he would
say like oh I accept you though like for
who you are and like love everything
about you and then when he got really
mad one day he like started doing very
abusive things and then he was like
you're you sold your soul like all
these horrible things he was saying and
feeling like you could finally trust
someone and then them saying all those
horrible things and like doing all those
bad things you're like oh so you
pretended that whole time and I really
trusted you and loved you and now you're
over here saying that I'm a dirty
that sold her soul I don't think I sold
my soul I just think I was young and
dumb didn't know what to do and I was
desperate to survive that's it I wasn't
doing this because I thought it was a
great fantastic idea that everyone was
going to um see me naked I just really
needed to survive and that was the
quickest way it's either that or drugs
or selling drugs so I was like that
those are the two things that make the
fastest money is drug dealers
and um I don't know what the word is sex
workers sex workers yeah yeah I was
going to say horse but that's bad you're
not a hor sex workers yeah and so it
makes fast money but it's addictive and
it's not good it's not good money did
you ever feel good about it like when
you when you would get it your at the oh
my gosh it felt amazing it felt like a
drug it was like I have all this money I
can like basically do whatever I want
like it was like I could take trips I
could do this I it keeps growing right
yeah like it was just it was so crazy I
would refresh my screen every day have
like days I would make $5,000 in a day
and I was like this is crazy like I love
it and then when people started treating
me different my parents found out my um
my whole family my friends everybody
found out um that's when it really got
bad I was like why did I do that now now
no one likes me so and everyone brings
it up at some point like oh but you did
that so you can't really be mad about it
like you did that to yourself and I'm
like I know but it's not something that
I
really was expecting for it to get this
out of hand like I thought it was just
some way to make fast money and I was
too deep into it so I had to like pull
myself out and save
myself it was crazy yeah it was crazy
your your story is very interesting yeah
I mean I think I I bet you it's a common
story that a lot of very attractive
women will have yeah I always say if I
could give advice to my younger self or
to any girl that's thinking about it
it's
like think about all the things that
come with it yes is a quick way to make
money but think not even just only fans
but like doing other things sex work
types like think about how it's going to
affect you in the future mentally like
emotionally like with your friends and
family like people close to you think
about all that stuff don't just like
jump into it cuz it looks like an
amazing fun idea because on the internet
they make it seem so great and amazing
but it's really not what they portray it
to be so no but so so many people are
just so tempted by the F the big money
yeah very
few young people especially will have
the the morals to to resist that and and
take a different path yeah so it's very
admirable admirable that you're doing
that yeah I would definitely maybe I'd
start like a a podcast or something
where I start talking about that stuff
so maybe more girls will see it and be
like okay like this is not something I
want to do I'm just saying really think
about it before you jump into something
like that it's going to change your life
and it could change your life in a
really bad way you being very attractive
you get a lot of hate yeah and it's like
I I think that's a super interesting
conversation to have cuz like you didn't
you didn't you didn't do anything to
cause that you you're not asking for it
this is just the way you were born yeah
maybe you have Lip lip gloss on and
maybe you're wearing a sexy top but it's
just that's your right to do that as a
as a woman yeah um definitely people
judge me more think I'm dumb think that
I don't deserve respect just because of
the way I look or the way I dress I'm
like there's so much more to me than
just my looks that's what I mean why I
was saying like guys just kind of use me
as a trophy right but but but if you can
imagine yourself looking the way you do
and develop your intellect and your
strength yeah whether it's law school or
something else yeah and just make
yourself so incredible so
strong that's what I always so focused
yeah you'll Crush any man any female
you'll run circles around him and and
you you'll be you'll be an impressive
Force to to to deal with I always dream
I can see that for you especially when
people do things like that to me or say
things like that to me I'm like one day
they're really going to see me and how
all the great things I'm going to do and
they're going to be like oh like
why did I treat her that way that's not
the way like you should do it for
yourself but I sometimes think about
that too no I mean using
negative yeah experiences like that as
fuel for motivate yourself to do
something great is is there nothing
wrong with that yeah that's what I've
done my whole life yeah definitely
especially because they think I can't do
it that makes me even that's how Michael
Jordan became the best basketball player
in the history of basketball he's the
angriest basketball player ever you saw
his Hol of famic acceptance speech oh
wow so I think I I think you have
tremendous potential and I think you
could do something like that if you just
put your mind to it I hope so and don't
and don't just rely on your your looks I
pray about it every day I pray about
that every day so it hurts I pray and I
ask God like why like why this like why
me but then at the same time I'm very
grateful for everything he has done for
me so on one side I'm like why did this
happen to me on the other side I'm like
okay but look how strong this has made
me and all the lessons it's taught me
and now things I could teach other
people yeah so you you've been giving
this you you've been given this
responsibility and you need to like
accept it
and do something with it yeah rather
than just being a empty shell that's
really beautiful yeah yeah I want to
show the world that there's more to me
and even now like some people watch this
and still think like oh but she they'll
still hate you yeah those they still
like it'll be in the comments all the
all the envious haters that wish they
look like you and oh this this stuck up
this this spoiled little brat or
this whatever yeah are ungrateful like
because of all the money like I am
grateful for it because of all the
things I could do with it like all the
things I did with it but at the same
time it's like a blessing and a curse
like the curse part is like everyone now
knows all these things about you
everyone has seen you naked you made
mistake a lot of people make mistakes
yeah doesn't mean you're a bad person
yeah I'm not a bad person at all I
probably have one of the purest Hearts I
know I'm so caring towards everyone I
want the best for everyone I just wish
one day I could get that back like I'm
sure you can yeah I'm sure you will
that's that's all I really want that's
all I really pray for is getting that
love and kindness and peace back that's
all I want is peace and love I don't
know what love is I don't really have
never had a peaceful life so it's like
when is it going to be my turn to
finally experience
that so when you when you encounter a
guy like if you take your dog for a walk
and
you yeah do you wear a hat and
sunglasses just to kind
of so I don't but it's very like
nerve-wracking when I'm passing
especially by like a group of guys I get
very nervous and scared because I
already know what's coming like they're
going to start saying
sexual things or like I said they don't
think you're a person they don't see
that you are not just a sexual object
they see a pretty girl and they're like
or a sexy girl because pretty and sexy
are different so they just see like a
more sexy girl and they're like oh my
gosh like I want to have sex with her
and I could say all these nasty things
to her it happens in person it happens
on the internet everything like everyone
just doesn't grasp the concept that
you're an actual living person with
feelings they just think you're an
object and it's not the way to view a
human being and people will hear that
from you and be like oh this this stupid
yeah yeah it's hard because they
don't really understand like how hard it
is to not be able to leave your house
without someone sexualizing you no
matter what I wear actually someone will
still say something to me every time or
girls don't want me around their
boyfriends because they know that their
boyfriends are going to look at me or
I'll be walking down the street and
girls will like turn their boyfriend the
other way I'm like I don't want your man
like I
promise so yeah it's pretty hard and
then the reaction you get from women is
probably just as bad right yeah women
they pretend to be my friend for a
little bit and then I find out that
they're talking behind my back all the
terrible rumors that have started about
me because they spread everywhere I've
been called all kinds of crazy things
and like horrible comments and it's
usually women who start those like
rumors and stuff especially like bad
ones they'll be like oh she did this she
has a million sugar daddies like no I
don't you do feel like no one sees you
yeah I feel like no one sees the real
you yeah I definitely feel like no one
has had the chance to actually talk to
me immediately because they see you as a
threat or a sexual object yeah either
it's women and men so I get both sides
so I don't have anybody are are you
lonely it must be a lonely life right
yeah it is lonely it is very lonely I
like I said I only have one gay best
friend he's the only one that I can
really say like is truly my friend and
it's because he's not envious because he
doesn't think I'm going to steal his man
or something like and he's not
sexualizing me because he's not
attractive that's great that you have
someone do have someone that is shout
out to him because he he really whenever
I have any issue or like I'm really
depressed or like I really need help I
can call him and I know he'll be there
that's wonderful yeah but I wish I had
more of that like I really wish that
there's more people that would just know
me and like treat me like a human being
and not like this fasy like I'm a human
not just something that you want to have
sex with so yeah no your your challenge
is you're going to have a big challenge
ahead of you yeah that's why I want to
like do bigger things so it's like I do
more more with my life than just that
especially when it comes down
to
very like I've had even celebrities like
sexualize me and they they pre on me
because I was so young I was 1920 when I
would meet some of these 40-year-old
like men can't say who they were but
they were like sexualizing me and
wanting to do all these things with me
and taking advantage of me just because
of the way I looked and how young and
dumb I was so can't trust
anybody one day and you're not you're
not going to be able to be dumb yeah
looking the way you do yeah you'll just
get taken advantage you have yeah you
have to be very strong and smart and
aware I think that's your responsibility
is to figure out get your intuition and
just your intelligence up so you you can
see through what everyone is doing yeah
yeah cuz you you have a different
challenge than most most women do yeah
and it's hard to understand if you're
not experiencing it cuz some people are
going to watch this and be like oh she's
so she's so stuck
up oh she's complaining about being too
pretty look at that but they don't
really see like how lonely and bad it
can actually get so yeah it's pretty
it's pretty difficult yeah
yeah all right Bri thank you so much for
sharing your story I wish you all the
luck in the world I hope you do great
things with your life thank you all
right thank you very
much
I